it can be tough to figure out what to
stream next to netflix's vast library
but don't worry
from incredible underrated gems to
timeless favorites that you haven't
thought about in years
we've rounded up the best movies on
netflix right now
after the amazing spider-man 2
effectively killed a franchise as we
knew it it came as a bit of a shock when
sony pictures announced that they'd be
moving forward with their own new
spider-man project
after agreeing sharing the webslinger
with marvel studios that task seemed all
the more daunting when spider-man
homecoming arrived like the john hughes
spider flick we didn't know we needed
then came sony's animated spider-man
into the spider-verse which proved that
the movie multiverse was big enough for
more than one spider-man not to mention
a spider gwen a spider-ham and a giant
anime robot from the future
into the spider-verse briefed a welcome
life into both the rapidly tiring
superhero
genre and the stagnating medium of
feature animation that life arrived via
miles morales who seeks to replace the
recently deceased spider-man of his
world
only to discover that there are several
spider folks spread across multiple
dimensions
and that a singular threat is about to
disrupt each of their realities
the story chock full of equal parts
drama comedy and heartfelt soul
unfolds in an electrifying visual style
designed to literally bring comic book
pages to life
that hearty combination of style and
substance makes into the spider-verse
unlike any other superhero flick out
there
it's easy to forget but prior to 2005's
batman begins
there wasn't a lot of support behind
making a new batman flick that had a lot
to do with the sour taste joel
schumacher shamelessly indulging confess
batman and robin left and the mouths of
bat fans are welled over
so when a then relatively unknown
christopher nolan signed up to bring the
dark knight's big screen saga back to
its former glory
it definitely raised a few eyebrows when
batman begins finally hit theaters in
the summer of o5
those eyebrows went from wearily rays to
wide-eyed with glee almost overnight
rather than the neon drenched visuals
and the over-the-top puns this was a
batman film so many fans have been
waiting for a gritty action-packed
character drama
about a troubled young man embracing his
inner heart of darkness in the wake of
witnessing
his parents brutal murder the fact that
said man was bruce wayne played with
equal parts charm and pathos by
christian bale and that his heart of
darkness led him to become the vigilante
known as batman
only made the story more intriguing
while nolan and company packed in plenty
of the white knuckle action one would
expect in any caped crusader tale
throughout batman begins the film had an
incredible passion for character
particularly michael kane's pitch
perfect alfred
it's a problem with a graphite sir the
next 10 000
will be up to specifications at least
they gave us a discount
ultimately that led nolan's backflip to
do something no other batman movie had
before
resonate with viewers on a deeply human
level
in 2010 graphic novel fans were excited
for scott pilgrim vs the world and not
just because they liked the source
material the news of the film was to be
directed by edgar wright
then a burgeoning cult icon hot off the
success of sean of the dead and hot furs
left fans downright impatient for it to
arrive in theaters
wright delivered the goods crafting an
action-packed genre bursting romantic
comedy with enough razor sharp wits and
a bit charm to claim success it also
featured a hip young cast with seen
stealing appearances from future
mcu stars chris evans and brie larson
with that pedigree and reviews to match
scott pilgrim vs the world seemed
destined for bugs off his glory
but sadly that didn't happen in fact the
film was an outright bomb that seemed
doomed to claim little more than cult
classic status
luckily wright's hipster opus found
second life on video and is now counted
amongst the director's best work
if you've been sleeping on the fact
now's the time to get into the game
horror fans are currently enjoying a
golden age of scary cinema
it seems like every single week a smart
scary confection is hitting theaters to
rave reviews and box office conquest
sadly that means that every year there's
a buried treasure that goes unnoticed
much like a body stashed in a shallow
grave one of the more overlooked gems of
late has to be the 2016 pseudo-haunted
house chiller the autopsy of jane doe
from director andrei ubradol if you
recognize uber doll's name
it's likely because you saw his 2010
found footage masterpiece trollhunter
if you're wondering why you never heard
about this follow-up well the film
received virtually no promotion from
distributors
enroute to its theatrical release and
was all but ignored by audiences and
theaters
luckily upridel's atmospheric creeper
has garnered legit cult classic status
via streaming platforms so if you've yet
to experience some morbid delights
within the autopsy of jane doe
there's no time like the present without
spoiling anything the film is part
haunting and procedural mystery and part
gory ghoulish fight fest
centered around the gruesome act of the
title ubra doll makes marvelous use of
the film's grim
single location a morgue and nothing can
quite prepare you for the grisly mystery
unfolding within
first published in 2004 the epic
mind-bending sci-fi novel cloud atlas
was hailed in some literary circles as a
visionary work of speculative fiction
which unsurprisingly made many readers
believe that it would be totally
impossible to adapt to the big screen
clearly nobody told tom diego or the
wachowskis that fact
and the adventurous trio set out to
bring their sprawling star-studded and
ambassadorly ambitious adaption of cloud
atlas to the world a few years later
only to see the world pretty much ignore
it that was the world's last
set over six different time periods the
film features a brilliant ensemble cast
fronted by tom hanks halle berry hugh
grant
and susan sarandon all playing multiple
roles throughout
the loosely intertwined narratives start
and stop with little notice
making cloud atlas an admittedly
challenging slice of experimental cinema
for the blockbuster audience it targeted
and if those elements weren't enough to
scare that audience off the film's
almost three-hour run time was probably
enough to seal the deal
i think you're gonna love this
those brave enough to buy the ticket and
take the supremely wild ride
were rewarded with a visionary work of
cinematic daring so full of visual
thrills
star human drama and complex
philosophical ideologies that it could
spin the head of even the savviest of
audiences
to those who miss out we'd wager this
marvellous head trip of a film
will be a bit more digestible in the
comforts of your own home
in the summer of 2007 a teaser that ran
for just under two minutes alongside the
brand new transformers film made
moviegoers way more intrigued than any
of michael bay's robotic trucks ever did
the unlabeled inexplicable monster movie
ad from jj abrams and the bad robot team
had fans buzzing for months to find out
the name of the film it teased with a
groundbreaking viral marketing campaign
that ensured they would stay hooked
until the movie was released by the time
cloverfield made its premiere the next
january the fans were beyond fever pitch
against all odds cloverfield directed
with fevered urgency by matt reeves and
bolstered by drew goddard's agile
scripting
didn't just meet his lofty expectations
it far surpassed them
reeves and goddard delivered the humane
grounded monster movie masterpiece a
generation of film goers never knew they
needed
using a found footage style to give the
audience a first person view of the city
stomping kaiju action
over a decade later cloverfield still
packs the same visceral punch that it
did upon release
and remains a fascinating entry point to
the cinematic world building experiments
that led to the underrated 10
cloverfield lane and the compelling
disaster that was the cloverfield
paradox
which like cloverfield itself are far
more rewarding with repeat viewings
in the years since you broke onto the
international film scene in the early
2000s
south korean author bong joon has become
one of the most respected filmmakers
working today
that's mostly thanks to one of the most
adventurous filmographies cinema has
ever seen
his string of surprises just kept going
in 2013 when he adapted a little-known
graphic novel called snowpiercer that
his english language debut
though many foreign filmmakers struggled
in adapting their style to american
markets
bong took the challenge in stride and
delivered one of the more bracingly
original sci-fi films of the modern era
snowpiercer unfolds on a speeding train
that spent 17 straight years cutting
through a desolate landscape decimated
by a failed climate change experiment
and even amongst us to ragdoll's
eclectic filmography it's one hell of a
ride
as with much of bong's work it's also
politically charged with climate science
in play outside the train and class
warfare boiling inside we wouldn't dare
spoil one wild minute of this film for
those who haven't seen it but with an
incredible performance by chris evans
that gets pretty far from captain
america
things get crazy in wage who cannot
fathom and that's a very good thing
in the 35 years since joe dante's
gremlins theaters there's been an
ongoing debate about how the film should
be classified
some think it's a classic black comedy
full of slapstick violence
others think it's a gory horror flick
while others think it's a treatise
against the commercialization of the
holiday season
there are even folks who think it's the
greatest christmas movie ever made for a
certain definition of christmas movie
the only thing you need to understand
about gremlins is that gremlins doesn't
give a hoot how you classify it
so yes gremlins is a dark comedy yes
it's an anti-commercial christmas movie
and yes it's a classic slice of creature
feature horror to boot delivering one of
the cutest creatures to ever grace the
silver screen in gizmo and ingeniously
ensuring that the cuter than cute
creature inadvertently spawns the
murderously grotesque monsters that give
the film its name
look we aren't trying to tell you how to
watch gremlins as long as you actually
watch it
just know that whether you're seeing it
for the first time or the 20th it's that
rarest of creepy
socially conscious creature feature
comedies that delivers a few new
surprises with every single watch
one of michael mann's earliest claims to
fame came when he leveraged his penchant
for tough guy crime tales and his edgy
sense of call to maximum effect as a key
creative force behind smash hit tv
series miami vice
in the years since that show ended in
1990 man has built a reputation as a
visionary cinematic stylist who martin
square ceti once called one of the
finest filmmakers in america
still it was a bit of a surprise that a
quarter century after the show was
cancelled
man signed on to write and direct a big
screen adaptation of the series to the
surprise of exactly no one man delivered
a slick neo-noir thriller
steeped in a suave machismo that made
the series a hit though he did so sans
the buddy cop camp that helped soften
the edges of the series
make no mistake miami vice driven by a
pair of unflappably stoic performances
from jamie foxx and colin farrell is an
almost absurdly serious film if you're
willing to buy into that super serious
tone though
you'll likely see it for exactly what it
is a subtly subversive razor sharp crime
drama with style and
energy to burn all of which makes it a
pitch perfect entry into man's already
incredible filmography
of all the noteworthy filmmakers who
broke through in the 90s few did so with
quite as much verve as guy richie the
british director made the scene with
stylish kinetic and laugh out loud
hilarious keeper comedies and delivered
what might be his best work in 2000
titled simply snatch the film saw richie
building on the styles and themes that
made his first hit
lock stuck into smoking barrels such a
refreshing cinematic endeavor
the breakneck cutting outlandish
violence and zinging dialogue from
low-level criminal losers bundling
towards a big score
delivered a devilishly over-the-top
crime adventure it's a classic crime
story complete with a mcgovern as the
entirety of london's criminal
underground from bare knuckle boxing
promoters to russian gangsters go on the
hunt for a priceless stolen diamond
there is the stove
my conveyor system in service of
bringing this marvelously mad cab
diamond dash to life
richie enlisted an impressive a-list
cast of us and uk players
including benicio del toro and the then
relatively unknown jason statham along
with tough guy footballer turned actor
vinnie jones
and of course a big name star brad
pierre hey man
come on look at the size of this fella
[ __ ] your back's a little conscious
ah you look like a bachelor
pitt's involvement drew american
audiences to the theater and as solid as
the cast is top to bottom his miraculous
turn as a shifty tough as nails nearly
incomprehensible boxer absolutely steals
the show
and helps transform richie's clever
genre retread into a crackerjack crime
comedy for the ages
today jennifer lawrence is one of the
most beloved and recognizable stars in
hollywood but prior to 2010
you would have been hard-pressed to find
anyone at all who knew her name if
you're at all familiar with laurence's
meteoric rise to legit superstardom you
know the ascension began when she landed
the lead in the gritty micro budget
drama winter's bone
as good as she's been in much of her
work since laurence's performance in
winter's bone remains her best
her raw talent is full on display
throughout this diamond of her film
and we can thank director debra granick
for that who cast lawrence against type
as a dirt poor toughest nails ozark teen
desperate to find her missing
meth-dealing father in order to find the
missing man she's forced to dive
headlong down a rabbit hole full of
nefarious backwards-dwelling characters
who value their community strict code of
silence above all else chief among them
is her enimatic addicted uncle teardrop
played by john hawks and one of the best
supporting performances ever committed
to film
who's harboring some serious ill will
toward his missing brother
you always have scared me
that's cause you're smart to say any
more would be to take the sting right
out of this brutal beautifully brooding
little drama and this is one mystery
whose secrets are worth discovering and
rediscovering for yourself
set in a vividly realized not too
distant future her follows a kind lonely
man who finds love in the most
unexpected place with an ai driven
operating system named samantha
on paper that plot sounds a bit
ridiculous and in the hands of a lesser
filmmaker
it probably would have been with spike
jones at the helm hers potentially silly
setup becomes a tenderly observed study
of longing
for and fighting connection in a tech
obsessed world driven to isolationism
at the center of that world is a
transcendent performance from joaquin
phoenix
who brings of warmth wit and compassion
to this role the supporting roles are
fantastic too
with a scene-stealing turn from amy
adams and dynamic voice work from
scarlett johansson
who makes a fully developed character of
her artificial persona
as a sci-fi film her is a towering dp
personal achievement in style and
substance
as a social document it's a visionary
reflection on the world as it likely
will be
if you don't believe that just ask alexa
what she thinks
since breaking into hollywood with
1984's remarkably assured debut blood
simple
the coen brothers joel and ethan have
gone on to produce a near unimpeachable
body of work
their films have found them working well
in virtually every genre
from slapstick fast romantic comedy to
elaborate crime stories
and even the occasional musical numbers
whatever story they choose to tell you
can be certain of one thing
the coens are always going to push to do
something they haven't done before
though it features all the staples fans
have seen before
their 2018 western the ballad of buster
scruggs finds the currents pushing
themselves farther than ever
first time
of course the thing that most obviously
sets the ballad of buster scruggs apart
from the rest of their films
is that it's an anthology comprised of
six short tales of the wild west
rather than a single straightforward
narrative those six tales are thrilling
and hilarious and frequently downright
heartbreaking and features stellar work
from an all-star cast including james
franco liam neeson and tom waits
each one is fueled by the sort of mirth
or madness only joel and ethan cohen can
conjure
coupled with jaw-dropping digital
cinematography and pitch perfect western
themes from composer carter burrell
the ballad of buster scruggs is easily
one of the best movies netflix has ever
produced
and has a good claim on being one of
2018's best films
2018 may or may not have brought an
official end to robert redford's nearly
six decade acting career
but retirement should offer him a little
more time in the director's seat
that's a good thing because redford's
work behind the camera has often been as
thrilling as his work in front even
earning him an academy award in 1981
in the years since winning that oscar
redford has remained choosy with his
directorial efforts
helming only nine movies since of those
films 1994's quiz show is arguably his
best work
set in the 50s it tells the true story
of one of television's most famous
scandals
the film follows a working-class man and
a member of one of america's most
prominent families
as they face off on the hit tv quiz show
21 which was infamously and illegally
rigged by the show's producers and
eventually exposed by an idealistic
government attorney that may not sound
like the blueprint for
a thrilling character-driven
biographical drama about corruption and
classism in america but that's just what
redford delivered
like the story it so elegantly explores
quiz show is almost too intriguing to
believe
and remains one of the best films of the
90s check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you